what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with Defenders Beyond and blue
Marvel fights the Phoenix Force plus
we're also going to find out uh how the
beyonder ranks in comparison to the
Phoenix
I'm curious to see how you guys respond
so as we covered in the last video
basically blue Marvel The Defenders and
them had come across the beyonders and
we got what was in effect the new origin
of the beyonders in Marvel Comics they
were effectively created by the
celestials and given enough power to
ensure they could destroy the celestials
if they needed to and so what we ended
up finding at the end of that story is
that the Defenders passed through the
beyonders and into the next stage of
existence right the higher planes as it
was called and into the white hot room
now this requires a bit of a discussion
here and this is one of the things I
wanted to hold off until this video so
in Marvel Comics a lot of you guys are
aware of the Phoenix Force even if you
don't necessarily know the ins and outs
of the Phoenix Force the idea behind the
Phoenix is that there is only one
Phoenix Force throughout the entirety of
the Multiverse and even Omniverse but in
Marvel Comics in recent years they've
used Multiverse and Omniverse
interchangeably so they more or less
mean the same thing in Marvel Comics now
but the idea behind it is there's only
ever one Phoenix Force just like there's
only one Living Tribunal the idea behind
the Phoenix though is that it represents
the sum total of all life that has ever
currently does and will ever exist
throughout the Multiverse now we know
just by nature of the history of Marvel
Comics not even including Jonathan
Hickman's Avengers and New Avengers that
the Multiverse does have an end date it
will end naturally at some point in time
so that's how Marvel creates a sort of
cap to the power of the Phoenix but when
you're talking about a level of power
that high the cap on the Phoenix forces
Powers is so astronomically up there you
might as well consider that it doesn't
even exist because there'd be very very
few instances where you would see the
Phoenix Force go up against a level of
power that it just cannot handle the
only real exception to this is when the
Phoenix takes on a physical host The
Perfect Host was Jean Gray right that's
why Jean Gray and the Phoenix are so
synonymous it has taken on the bodies of
beings like Quentin choir or at least in
an alternate reality it did in alternate
reality Franklin Richards became the
Phoenix Rachel Summers is a popular host
for the Phoenix but the Phoenix's
ability to utilize those avatars is
relative to what the Avatar's bodies can
handle so it's like pouring water in a
glass if you pour too much it's going to
overflow the Overflow equivalent in
Marvel Comics is that physical being
dying right that's basically what that
is and so the white hot room is
basically this place within the
Multiverse whereby the Phoenix Force
resides it's its home and it's in the
white hot room that the Phoenix force is
at the absolute peak of its power and so
one of the things to know is that as
they pass into this place they are in
the white hot room it's where the
Phoenix is its most capable you'll never
find the Phoenix Force ever being more
powerful than it is when it's in the
white hot room now the first person that
we initially pick up with is Tigra and
Tigra doesn't fully understand what's
going on here instead they've all seemed
to have kind of arrived in different
locations really within the white hot
room if there is such a thing and the
result is that Tigra initially
communicates with the Phoenix right
literally the Phoenix pops up and it
says I am Fire and Life incarnate and my
wings beat Thunder I am the glory at the
heart of all things the Roaring flame of
mercy and terrible judgment Beyond me
there is Darkness human Darkness Without
End do you understand now here's the
thing to understand there is a realm
beyond the realm of the Phoenix and
that's something that I hope you guys
are really picking up on here with what
Al Ewing's doing he's kind of building
it in layers right he's like there's the
main Marvel universe beyond the main
Marvel Universe there is the Multiverse
beyond the Multiverse there's the Beyond
verse beyond the Beyond verse there is
the white hot room beyond the white hot
room is a place that we will see at the
end of this comic and actually in the
next comic as well what's ironic about
that is that if you have an Eagle Eye in
Marvel Comics really in the events
leading up to Jonathan Hickman's
Avengers and New Avengers are really
Secret Wars you know what room we're
talking about it's a really really cool
place it's a place that the Silver
Surfer visited once so there's a really
awesome location but the thing about
this is we switch over to Adam Brashear
now Adam Brashear in communicating with
the Phoenix Force it's one of these cool
things because Adam kind of asked where
you have like this construction worker
who's building things and working on
stuff Adam asked the question is that
being an Avatar of you now the reality
of this is that Al Ewing is sort of
building on an old story that was done
back in the day where basically Jean
Gray had met mistress death in the form
of a guy now I want to say it was during
dark Phoenix that's one of those areas
of Marvel Comics where as much as I love
the X-Men the memories do get a little
murky and so I can't necessarily recall
the location of the comic isn't overly
important here what is important is that
when Jean Gray Met Death that death was
actually building these pillars in her
own realm and these pillars were
basically the afterlife for every
individual being who died now that was
Chris claremont's depiction of the realm
of death it has different depictions
based on who you're talking to if you
read a comment by Jim Starlin that
features Thanos in the realm of mistress
death it'll be shown one way right so
it's just it really depends on who's
drawing and writing and interpreting the
story and so on and so forth but the
important thing here is that what the
Phoenix says is the reason why this
construction workers building is because
the job of the Phoenix is to always
build now that's true and that's been a
thing since Grant more since here comes
tomorrow during his new X-Men run the
idea behind the Phoenix by and large
right while it does exist and it does
have an incredible amount of power when
Grant Morrison initially introduced the
quote-unquote core rule of the Phoenix
that it was very very nebulous right it
was just like I exist to fix what's
broken well what the hell does that mean
Grant Morrison like I mean nobody knows
what that like what does it mean to fix
what's broken like what if something's
kind of broken a little bit but not
really right if a glass is cracked do
you take it to a person who's going to
be able to like fix it or do you just
say you know what we'll wait till it
starts leaking water like how does that
how does that work right I mean how do
you square that Circle and so the role
behind the Phoenix is that it's always
building basically new universes new
places where people can reside where
life can grow so it's kind of the
Wellspring of all existence and so Adam
Brashear ever the scientist really has
more questions than anything else and
the answers that he gets are just very
very nebulous and very ambiguous right
he's literally like he asked a question
so what does that make him right the
construction worker your creation and
aspect of your being and there the
response to the construction worker is I
am as I am Adam Brashear and I'm working
there's always the new to build on the
old always the schedule to keep and so
his question is so your God or your
death am I getting warm at least like
give me some kind of an answer and he
doesn't really get one but from here we
switch over to America Chavez now
America Chavez of course is also visited
by the Phoenix and as she's making her
way through this kind of endless desert
the Phoenix literally tells her you've
lost what it was that made you unique
you can get it back but it's going to be
a very very arduous task now what the
Phoenix is referring to here is that
when America Chavez was initially
introduced into Marvel Comics she was a
character that had the ability to jump
through realities that was her thing
much like what you saw in Doctor Strange
2 Multiverse of Madness a giant star
would appear she'd jump through it that
star was a portal she'd end up somewhere
else initially it happened without her
ability to control to a degree as time
progressed she gained more control over
it and that allowed her to jump in and
out of whatever reality she wanted to so
long as she was aware of where it was
and so as a result of that it's really
Al Ewing saying the ability for her to
regain her powers does exist and that
will eventually happen it'll just take a
little bit before it does at that point
we switch over to Loki and the beyonder
now this is where things get really
really interesting here and I'm really
curious to see how you guys feel about
this right the beyonder versus the
Phoenix I'm curious to see what you guys
think so one of the first things the
beyonder does is he basically makes a
food processor because the beyonder can
just do virtually anything it wants to
and just craft something out of nothing
right it's just the nature of the
beyonder's power he's as close as you
get to God but the funny thing about
this is that when Loki asked the
question the beyonder says I made it
when we landed forging the base quarks
that was the hard part right basically
making it was the hard part do you want
to blend anything I find it's comforting
in moments like this and when Loki asks
moments like what the response to the
beyonder moments when I'm outclassed
silly if you hadn't trapped me in a
narrative Arc I'd never have come here I
mean I'm omnipotent of course
technically speaking but against the
pure Phoenix Force actually inside the
White hot room we're probably going to
end up like Mr Carrot here so what Al
Ewing is establishing is the Phoenix
force in its most pure form it's more
powerful than the beyonder now there's
room to make this argument here there's
room to make this argument because
remember every single time anyone's ever
gone up against the beyonder Rachel
Summers when she was the Phoenix
fighting the beyonder in secret Wars 2
when Cyclops was killed by God King Doom
wielding the power of the beyonders when
he had the Phoenix force or at least
when Cyclops had the Phoenix Force every
time we've seen the Phoenix face off
against the beyonder it's always been
the Phoenix with a physical host and the
Phoenix's power is always diminished
when it has a physical host because
outside of Jean Gray no one's been able
to wield the full totality of the
Phoenix and become the white Phoenix of
the crown in its most pure form so Al
Ewing is actually going with credible
evidence here right given the fact that
the Phoenix force is absolute power life
incarnate it stands to reason you could
make an argument the Phoenix could
defeat the beyonder now some people will
kind of like say no that's ridiculous
largely because it's just like the
Beyond are supposed to be like the most
powerful being out there next to God and
if we're talking about the original
beyonder from Secret Wars one and two
yes but lest we forget and the Fantastic
Four stories that were done back in the
day that retcon happened the beyonder's
power was reduced by about half so that
kind of begs the question in terms of a
tried and true beyonder which is what
this guy now is would the Phoenix be
able to defeat it I'm not 100 sure
there's no definitive answer here
because I don't think there's really any
credible evidence to offer either way
outside of some stuff that Phoenix has
done some stuff that beyonder's done
comparing the two of them and coming to
a conclusion so here's what I want the
comic book YouTube Community not just
the fans anybody in the comic book
YouTube Community who finds who who
wants to get into this give me an answer
because I'm curious right I mean I'm
sure people are going to power scale do
a little bit of cooking of the books but
you know let me know right what do you
think would actually happen here like do
you think the pure Phoenix Force could
actually defeat the beyonder that it is
more powerful than the beyonder I'm
curious right somebody gave me some some
answers here because honestly I'm
excited to see if anybody can figure it
out but the thing about this is that
once this sort of statement is known
right once this thing is known we
basically jump back to of course the
Phoenix sort of taunting Loki and the
beyonder a little bit the Loki's kind of
ignoring her more than anything else and
one of the things that Phoenix says is
that that version of Loki has to be
destroyed because it's a Loki out of
time remember that's one of the things
that we covered that leading up to
Jonathan Hickman's Secret Wars Marvel
had stories that were called uh the last
days of whoever in the heck was in that
story in this instance the last days of
Loki that Loki basically skipped over
the entirety of Secret Wars went through
a portal went back in time and that's
how he's here but Loki is not actually
supposed to be here right now he's
supposed to be dead he was supposed to
have been wiped away with everything
right with the Multiverse and then be
reborn as its current self so it's one
of those weird things it's a little
weird and a little murky and kind of
wonky but just understand this version
of Loki is not supposed to exist and so
that's what the Phoenix is talking about
here when it says you're supposed to be
burned away You're supposed to be gone
but switching over to this fight between
blue Marvel Adam Brashear and uh and the
Phoenix Force the fight between the two
is really really intriguing here and the
reason why is because Al Ewing is
building on this in the sense that one
Al Ewing is probably the second most
prolific writer of Adam Brashear outside
of Kevin grievius who made him right for
those of you guys who are really
familiar with that Kevin grievius made
Adam Brashear and then Al Ewing wrote
the heroic age story I believe where uh
where Adam Brashear fought Hyperion from
a different universe but after that all
of the appearances of Adam brashear's
character in Marvel Comics have all been
written by Al Ewing the mighty Avengers
led by Luke Cage was Al healing the
ultimate Al Ewing this is all Al Ewing
that's been writing his character so
he's pretty well versed and what he's
capable of the Phoenix Force for all of
its power and all of his bravado and all
of its abilities is a being made of
positive matter so there is room albeit
arguing kind of fudging the numbers a
little bit there is room for Adam
Brashear to either be comparable to the
Phoenix Force even if only temporarily
or at least to negate its power because
that's antimatter versus positive matter
so again it's uh it's interesting here
it's one of those ways where it's
basically blue Marvel kind of getting a
power boost or Adam brochure getting a
power boost one that we hadn't normally
seen before because this will be
referenced across the internet people
will say well there was that time when
Adam Brashear went toe-to-toe against
the Phoenix and then somebody's going to
come back and say yeah but this and that
person is going to come back and say
yeah but that and this that's how it
works on the internet but it's just one
of those interesting things because in
the midst of the fight between the two
you do have the beyonder and Loki who
show up and the beyonder throws a food
processor at the Phoenix and hits her in
the head which is kind of weird but it's
one of those things where what it does
is it offers a momentary reprieve
because it allows America Chavez who's
basically returned to jump in and fight
the Phoenix now remember Over America
Chavez has the eternity mask which
grants her power that's equal to whoever
she's facing off against that's not even
an alewing invention as far as I'm aware
this thing's been around for years and
years and years of Marvel Comics what it
does is it allows everybody else the
time they need to basically start trying
to figure out a way out of there and
that's where you have Adam Brashear who
starts talking directly to uh to the
construction worker and it's kind of a
cool theme because while the
construction worker is doing all of this
Al Ewing does kind of hint to the idea
that the construction worker is not
associated with the Phoenix that it's
not necessarily directly with the
Phoenix itself and in fact one of the
things that construction worker says is
he says this place is a place of balance
between light and dark compassion and
severity mercy and destruction your
friends are acting out that balance
there's an argument for letting you all
Journey on just as there's an argument
for burning you to nothing and so Adam
asks like that's not a debate that I
want to risk playing out do you have any
advice mysterious stranger and this guy
says me I just work here you're are the
one leading eternity's Defenders you're
the one calling the plays and so it's an
interesting thing because what this guy
looks like is again he's not associated
with the Phoenix Force which is to say
he's not a part of the Phoenix now there
is a person in Marvel Comics recently
that has been talking about balance and
if any of you guys have read the the
newer Thanos one shot that came out that
recently retold his origin which we'll
cover tomorrow that mistress death says
that that mistress death is like no
Thanos is acting out of balance right
he's playing a bounce that kind of thing
so whether or not this is actually
mistress death is just one of those
things that's a mystery but again it is
cool to see that there's this kind of
figure out there that doesn't really
have a direct relation to the Phoenix
per se so again it's sort of fascinating
here because in the midst of all this
you have Adam Brashear that comes to
this realization that with somebody like
Tigra she's a lot more powerful than she
initially appears now here's the thing
about here's the thing about Greer
Nelson one I know most of you guys don't
care about Greer and that's fair she
sucks she always has and she's never
been interesting but the thing about her
character is that she gained her powers
and she plays a role similar to t'challa
of the Black Panther Mythos where
t'challa is an avatar of the panther
goddess best Tigra is an avatar of what
is basically the Tiger Force or the
Tiger God if you want to call it that it
all goes back to her origin her
professor named tumulo who basically
turned out to be a guy that was involved
with a whole bunch of magicians that
wore ships like a tiger goddess it's
weird and it's wonky and it's Marvel
Comics back in the day and it's one of
those stories didn't really make a whole
lot of sense the important thing here is
she's got a level of power that she
didn't know she had and she's never
tapped into before and so in doing so
what it does is that by utilizing this
power of the tiger God she kind of
communes with it channels its abilities
and then goes on to the affront
basically attacking the Phoenix now
again this is Al Ewing kind of offering
this idea the Phoenix force is powerful
but it's not the most powerful being out
there beyond that what it's also saying
is that yeah it's it's more powerful
than the beyonder but there are God is
out there that are more powerful than
the Phoenix what you're witnessing here
over the course of the story is Al Ewing
giving us a wholesale reshuffling of the
Marvel Cosmic Landscape of the power
hierarchy because in years past the
Marvel Comics right in years past what
you had is you had the one above all
then you had the beyonder then you had
the molecule man then you had everybody
else right the Living Tribunal and
Eternity and their powers fluctuated
based on the situation and who was
writing the stories so on and so forth
right then you had the introduction of
characters like the Marquee of death
Clyde wincham which elevated him to a
higher position you had characters with
caveats so like Thanos with the astral
regulator or Thanos with the heart of
the universe or Thanos with The Infinity
Gauntlet or whatever plot device Marvel
wants to create so he can go on some
crazy omnipotent scheme but whatever the
case is like you always had this kind of
established hierarchy among the cosmic
entities the gods so on and so forth
there's never been an instance where
we've ever looked at a character like
bass or any Earthly based God and
consider the possibility that they would
be on par with something as
astronomically powerful as the Phoenix
the Phoenix permeates the Multiverse
Bast is just a being over there who sits
in that chair and appears sometimes in
Marvel Comics and like that's it right
so like this God you know this this God
is this tiger god kind of falls in the
same vein so it is interesting to see
how Ewing just reshuffling so much of
this what the purpose is I'm not
entirely sure that's why stories like
this can kind of go either way either
this story is one where What's Happening
Here is going to permeate throughout the
entirety of the MCU so they're making
things a little more reasonable so the
Marvel Cinematic Universe can match it
the alternative is Al Ewing's doing this
because he wants to and he can right
because it's Al hewing and I'll read
anything this guy does and it's it's
awesome right so I mean again it's just
one of those funny and and sort of wonky
situations but in the midst of this
whole thing while this fight's going on
between basically the the Phoenix and
the tiger god again it gives the
Defenders the chance to move beyond the
realm of the white hot room and into
what's called The Abyss the Place Beyond
now once they're here they initially
have no idea what's here everything's
black and white there's no real color
here or anything everything's just sort
of drained out almost as if it's things
that haven't necessarily come to
fruition yet but the funny thing is when
they start asking questions and saying
like what in the world's going on here
like everything just feels so wrong in
this place a disembodied voice comes out
of nowhere and says of course it does
you all died by fire and now you're in
the abyss with me but don't worry even
here glorion can make your dreams come
true now here's the thing about glorion
right for those of you guys who don't
know anything about this guy this guy is
eight kinds of broken this guy's just
like eight not even just physically the
level of power this guy has is nuts he's
the most powerful being in Marvel Comics
that you've never heard of because this
guy draws his power from the shaper of
Worlds and the shaper of Worlds is
literally a walking talking Cosmic Cube
that's basically what this guy is this
guy can do anything now in years past he
hasn't been a being that was on par with
the Phoenix or more powerful than the
Phoenix or even the beyonders but what
it looks like Al Ewing is doing here is
saying that in this place right the land
of couldn't be shouldn't be which is
exactly what the abyss is that glorion
is the most powerful man walking and I'm
curious to see what in the world comes
out of this but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end thank you all for watching and I
will catch you all later
peace